THIS IS NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERONE CARILLO CERVANTES CHEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DAVIES FLORA
MICROPHONE VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORP QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO PLUS
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TAMED VELADERO S THE VALLAPUDUA
ARE VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WILSON. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. I ASKED WE PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL REFLECTION
YOUNGER SHOW CALLS FOR US TO
REMEMBER THE MILLIONS LOST TO
UNSPEAKABLE HATRED THE COURAGE
OF SURVIVORS THE HEROISM OF ALL
WHO FOUGHT FOR LIBERATION AND
PEACE. AND THE WOUNDS THAT HAVE
NOT AND WILL NOT EVER HEAL IT'S
ALSO A CALL TO ACTION. WE ARE
CALLED UPON TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TOXICITY OF HATE OF DEVICES
SPEECH THAT SEEKS TO OUR FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS COLLEAGUES AND
STRANGERS AS OTHERS IN A WAY
THAT DEPRIVES US ALL OF OUR
HUMANITY. WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THE ROLE THAT VITRIOL HAS PLAYED
IN FERMENTING HATRED AND THE
TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE FOLLOWED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY. AND ITS
PRESENCE TODAY IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE GLOBE AND IN OUR OWN
BACKYARD. AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE
OUR SHARED RESPONSIBILITY TO
HONESTLY CONFRONT INTOLERANCE
WHEREVER IT OCCURS. IN OUR HOMES
ARE ON THE FLOOR OF OUR
LEGISLATURE. IT'S ALSO INCUMBENT
UPON US AS LEADERS TO RESIST
SPEAKING WORDS WHICH FUEL HATRED
TO VISIT MR VIOLENCE AND INSTEAD
TO SEEK TO FOSTER EMPATHY
COMPASSION. AND THE SPIRIT OF
COMMUNITY AND SHARE STRUGGLE. TO
RECOMMIT TO END THE CYCLE OF
BIGOTRY AND VIOLENCE SO THAT OUR
CHILDREN AND GENERATIONS TO COME
CAN KNOW TRUE PEACE AND
EQUALITY. ME THAT PEACE BE WITH
US HERE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US IN THE
FIGHT. PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY TRIMMER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
MET AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
KELLY SAY ARE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTY SEVEN HIS PRESIDING SHE
PARKS PROGRAM A DESK RECORD
DAVID BOWMAN READING MYSTERY AS
MOVES AND MR FLOOR SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. PORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY. FOR
MEDICAL EAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
OUR QUE HAN. FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
. MISS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS RUBIO
MAIENSCHEIN TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORY TODAY.
AND I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL TO HAVE
GUESTS IN THE FLOOR. ON THE
FLOOR TODAY FOR THE OBSERVANCE
OF HOLOCAUST HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE AB EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN
MEDINA FOR THEIR HEARING ON
TUESDAY MAY THIRD. PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM IN
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHAL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB TWENTY
EIGHTY FIVE. HOLDEN FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ORDER THE BILL TO SECOND READING
THE BILL IS NO LONGER FISCAL.
FURTHER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE FRIEDMAN FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO SECOND
READING. THE BILL IS NOT FISCAL
. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
ONE FIVE TWO H. R. ONE OH ONE
JONES SAWYER FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THERE QUE HAN TO THE INACTIVE
FILE THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY. JOINING US IN THE GALLERY
. HIS FATHER GREGORY BOYLE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK ON YOUR DESKS
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GUIDED YO WELCOME. FATHER BOYLE
WILL BE IN THE WILLIE BROWN
CONFERENCE ROOM DURING SESSION
IF MEMBERS WISH WISH TO MEET
WITH HIM. ALSO JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY OUR MEMBERS OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES WELCOME. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE. THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE A WEEK.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR SIX TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE
NINETEEN FORTY ONE WITH OF A
SUITE THREE HUNDRED WITH THEM
IT'S NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WITH
THE BIGGEST TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
SIX. TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWO EIGHT TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE
WITH OF A SUITE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT MINUTES NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WITH WOMEN'S TWENTY
PROBABLY WITH MEMBERS TENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH MEMBERS TWENTY
THIRTY. MINUTES TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE WITH LIMITS TWENTY
FOUR THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO REMEMBERS TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THE MEMBERS TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOR THE WOMEN'S TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WITH HIS TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
MINUTES TWENTY FOUR. MINUTES
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN MINUTES
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO MINUTES
TWENTY SIX SEPTEMBER THE
MINISTRY I DON'T FOR THE MOMENT
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY TWO OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVENTY SIX OF
ELEVEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN
NINETEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE. SIX
SEVENTEEN. 575-817-3917
871-796-1805. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
FOUR NINETEEN OH SIX NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY
FORTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. 215-822-7220
329-244-2430. TWO TWENTY FOUR
FORTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO
TWENTY FOUR SIX. SIXTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR ANYWAY. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. FOUR AND FIVE TO FIVE
SEVEN. POINT SIX SEVEN TWO SIX
WILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THREE.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. 441-909-1930 NINE
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
210-721-0920 ONE FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE FIFTY FOUR TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
THREE ONE SIXTY THREE TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE TWENTY ONE NINETY
SIX TWENTY THREE ELEVEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO. 252-653-3260 TWENTY
SIX NINETY THREE. TWENTY NINE
SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WOULD HAVE BEEN SIXTEEN TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
TWO WITH A MINUTES TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY TO
THIRTY. MINUTES TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE WITH A MINUTES EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY
THREE PEOPLE OF EVENTS ANDERSON
MICHAEL. EIGHT EIGHTY THREE OF
THE MEMBERS. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ. ALL OF. WILL BE
DEEMED ADOPTED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR ACR ONE
SEVENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND DOLLARS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU MAY
OPEN THE MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO
PRESENT ACR ONE SEVENTY OUR
ANNUAL RESOLUTION FOR HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. NO DID HE RISE
YOM HASHOAH HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY COMMEMORATES THE
APPROXIMATELY SIX MILLION JEWS
AND COUNTLESS OTHERS WHO WERE
BRUTALLY MURDERED BY THE ****
AND THEIR COLLABORATORS. YANZHOU%
ALSO HONORS JEWISH RESISTANCE
DURING THE HOLOCAUST IT IS
OBSERVED ANNUALLY ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE WARSAW GHETTO
UPRISING. IN OBSERVING YOM
HASHOAH THE JEWISH CAUCUS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN COMMITTED TO
CENTERING THE VOICES OF
SURVIVORS. THE A SECTIONAL FEW
WHO THROUGH EXTRAORDINARY
RESILIENCE AN INCREDIBLE LOCKED
SURVIVED THE **** ATTEMPT TO
EXTERMINATE THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO AID IN THE
COVERED AGING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OUR ABILITY TO HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM SURVIVORS HAS BEEN
GREATLY DIMINISHED. BUT WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO TELLING
THEIR STORIES AND HONORING THEIR
LEGACY. SO TODAY AS PART OF
DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS ARE
HONORED TO SHARE THE STORIES OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS. THESE NARRATIVES
ARE ABOUT PEOPLE WE KNOW AND
LOVE FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHOSE
INCREDIBLE JOURNEYS SERVE AS AN
INSPIRATION. AND ENDED DURING
REMINDER OF WHY ARE CAUCUS DOES
THE WORK THAT WE DO. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN TODAY WITH THE STORY OF MY
FRIEND IN NEED OF FRIEDMAN. I
FIRST GOT TO KNOW NEED TO
BECAUSE HER SON ADAM AND I STUDY
TOGETHER TEL AVIV UNIVERSITY.
AND LATER BECAUSE OF HER
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP IN SO MANY
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS. I NEED
FAMILY WAS DEVASTATED IN THE
HOLOCAUST. HER SISTER TOTAL WAS
NINE WHEN SHE WAS MURDERED IN
THE GAS CHAMBERS IN TREBLINKA.
HER BROTHER OR NOT SHE WAS ONLY
A YEAR OLD WHEN THE **** THREW
HIM OUT OF A SECOND STORY WINDOW
AND THEN USED HIS BODY FOR
TARGET PRACTICE. HER UNCLE WAS
PUT INTO A PAIR OF ICY WATER IN
THE MIDDLE OF WINTER AND FROZEN
TO DEATH. TWO AUNTS WERE SUBJECT
TO HORRIFIC MEDICAL EXPERIMENTS
INCLUDING FOR STERILIZATION. HER
GRANDPARENTS WERE MURDERED SO
WE'RE COUNTLESS OTHER RELATIVES
. ALL TOLD I NEED A LOST MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FAMILY MEMBERS
IN THE HOLOCAUST. YEAH NEED AS
PARENTS WERE ANXIOUSLY SURVIVED
THE WAR BY JOINING THE PARTISANS
THE JEWISH RESISTANCE FIGHTERS
TO ESCAPE INTO THE FORESTS.
AFTER THE WAR THEY MADE THEIR
WAY TO THE UNITED STATES AS
STATELESS REFUGEES. I NEED A WAS
BORN SIX WEEKS LATER. SHE GREW
UP IN A COMMUNITY OF SIX HUNDRED
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR FAMILIES.
LIKE MANY IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
PEOPLE WORK TWELVE HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. I NEEDED IN
SPEAK ENGLISH UNTIL SHE WAS SIX
YEARS OLD. BY THAT TIME SHE KNEW
ALL OF THE STORIES ABOUT WHAT
HAD HAPPENED TO HER FAMILY AND
TO THE JEWS OF EUROPE. SHE
UNDERSTOOD THE CRIES IN THE
SCREAMS THE PEERS THE NIGHT TIME
SILENCE. THERE WAS NO MYSTERY AS
TO WHY THE ADULTS HAD NUMBERS
TATTOOED ON THEIR ARMS.
INCREDIBLY THE SURVIVORS IN HER
COMMUNITY WERE NOT FILLED WITH
ANGER AND HATE AND THOUGHTS OF
REVENGE. ON THE CONTRARY THEY
WERE FILLED WITH LOVE. DEVOTED
WITH ONE ANOTHER INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THEY TOOK CARE OF
EACH OTHER LOANED MONEY TO THOSE
IN NEED AND RAISE MONEY TO
SUPPORT THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
ABOVE ALL ELSE THEY FOCUSED ON
THEIR CHILDREN EVERYTHING WAS
ABOUT THE CHILDREN. I NEED A
LEARNED IMPORTANT LESSONS FROM
THE SURVIVORS. ABOUT WHAT REALLY
MATTERS IN LIFE. SHE LEARNED THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY. OF
CARING FOR THE VULNERABLE AND
ABOUT THE NEED FOR JEWISH POWER
IN JEWISH SELF DETERMINATION.
THESE LESSONS INFLUENCED HER
DEEPLY. SHE BECAME A SOCIAL
WORKER AND ADVOCATE FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES AND
TODAY SERVES AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF JEWISH FAMILY AND
CHILDREN'S SERVICES. ONE OF THE
MOST IMPACTFUL SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES IN OUR STATE. LIKE SO
MANY SURVIVORS AND THEIR
CHILDREN IN NEED IS ALSO DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT WE
TEACH OUR NEXT GENERATION ABOUT
THE HOLOCAUST AND PATTERNS OF
GENOCIDE. SHE HAS REMINDED ME
RESEARCH SHOWS THE HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION DEVELOPS
EMPATHY. REDUCES DISCRIMINATION
AND HATE AND INSPIRES MORAL
COURAGE AND A SENSE OF SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. EARLIER THIS
YEAR WAS SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA JEWISH FAMILY AND
CHILDREN'S SERVICES LAUNCH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE EDUCATION
TO HELP TEACHERS LEARN HOW
DEFECTIVE WE TEACH ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST AND OTHER GENOCIDES.
MEMBERS OF THE NEW STATEWIDE
COLLABORATIVE NETWORK INCLUDE
LEADERS FROM THE JEWISH ARMENIAN
CAMBODIAN RWANDAN SUDANESE UYGUR
AND INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES. OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS THIS
COLLABORATIVE WILL TEACH SEVEN
HUNDRED TEACHERS AND ULTIMATELY
IMPACTS SEVENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. BUT THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO GATHER WE HAVE A
COLLECTIVE OBLIGATION TO DO MORE
TO BRING THE LESSONS. CLEARLY
AND UNEQUIVOCALLY ABOUT CURRENT
GENOCIDES AND TO REDEDICATE
OURSELVES TO COMBATING ANTI
SEMITISM RACISM AND BIGOTRY OF
ALL FORMS. IN THAT SPIRIT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON ACR ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL WE HAVE SEVERAL SPEAKERS
WISHING TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MANY
OF YOU HAVE EVER HEARD ME TELL
THE STORY OF MY GRANDMOTHER- WHO
SMUGGLED HER AND HER MOM OUT OF
THE WARSAW GHETTO AS AS THE ****
CAME TO POWER. THIS MORNING I
SHARE A STORY OF A YOUNG WOMAN
WHO HAD A SIMILAR BEGINNING TO
LIFE- AND THEN HER LIFE ACTUALLY
GOT MUCH MUCH WORSE. HEADY ORTON
WAS BORN IN THE SMALL ROMANIAN
TOWN OF. A RED TAG. WHERE SHE
ENJOYED A SAFE AND COMFORTABLE
CHILDHOOD. HIS FATHER SAMUEL WAS
THE PRESIDENT THE LOCAL JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND HAD HE HAD MANY
FRIENDS FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND RELIGIONS. BUT
HER IDYLLIC CHILDHOOD STARTED TO
CHANGE WHEN SHE TURNED ELEVEN
AND WATCHED AS HER NEIGHBORSWERE ATTACKED IN THEIR HOMES
BURNED DOWN A BY AN ANTI SEMITIC
MOB. THINGS SOON GOT WORSE AND
SHE WAS WOKEN FROM HER SLEEP
WHEN OUR OWN HOMES WINDOWS WERE
SMASHED. THEIR HOUSE OF WORSHIP
NO LONGER FELT SAFE. WHAT
STARTED AS ISOLATED INCIDENTS
SOON LED TO FORMAL POLICIES THAT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST JEWS. THE
BEGIN WITH ANTI SEMITISM IN THE
SCHOOLS. AND CULMINATED WITH THE
ROUNDING UP OF ALL THE JEWS AND
SENDING THEM TO THE GHETTO. FOR
WEEKS HEADY IN OUR FAMILY WERE
IMPRISONED IN THE MUDDY FOREST.
WHERE DISEASE WAS RAMPANT. THE
ONLY FOOD THEY WERE GIVEN WAS
PORK WHICH WAS PROHIBITED BY
THEIR RELIGION AND ONLY MADE
AVAILABLE TO HIM YET HUMILIATE
THEM. HER FATHER WAS BEATEN SO
RUTHLESSLY HE COULD NOT STAND. A
NON JEWISH FAMILY FRIEND OFFERED
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ESCAPE.
BUT SHE REFUSED TO ABANDON HER
PARENTS. HEY DIDN'T BELIEVE
THINGS COULD GET ANY WORSE BUT A
MONTH LATER THEY DID. THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY WAS CRAMMED INTO A
WINDOWLESS CATTLE CARS SO
CROWDED NO ONE COULD SIT. FOR
THREE DAYS THEY HAD NO FOOD NOR
WATER DESPITE THE SWELTERING
HEAT. WHEN HEAVY AND OTHERS HAD
TO GO TO THE BATHROOM THEY WENT
WHERE THEY STOOD. WHEN H
ARRIVED IN AUSCHWITZ SHE WAS
SEPARATED FROM HER FATHER AND
GRANDMOTHER BOTH OF WHOM WERE
IMMEDIATELY SENT TO THE GAS
CHAMBERS. WHEN SHE ASKED ANOTHER
PRISONER ABOUT THE ASH FALLING
FROM THE SKY LIKE SNOWFLAKES AND
THE DARK CLOUDS OF SMOKE SHE WAS
TOLD IT WAS THE REMAINS OF HER
FATHER AND GRANDMOTHER. WHO HAD
BEEN INCINERATED IN THE CAMP'S
EVANS. HAD HE ONLY SURVIVED
AUSCHWITZ BECAUSE OF HER MOTHER
HELEN. WHO STARVED HERSELF SO
SHE COULD GIVE HEAVY THE TINY
BIT OF MORE THE BREAD AND WATERY
SOUP THEY RECEIVED. WHEN THE
**** EVACUATED AUSCHWITZ THEY
FORCED HEADED TO MARCH BAREFOOT
THROUGH THE SNOW FOR THREE DAYS
WITHOUT FOOD OR WATER. GERMAN
SHEPHERDS ATTACKED HEAVY IN THE
OTHER PRISONERS WHILE THE GUARDS
BEAT OR SHOT ANYONE WHO STUMBLED
. HER MOTHER WAS SO WEAK SHE
COULD NOT WALK HEAVY CARRIED HER
ON HER BACK FOR MUCH OF THE
DEATH MARCH. THIS WEEK MARKS THE
SEVENTY SEVEN TH THERE ARE THE
SEVENTY SEVEN YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF THEIR LIBERATION. SADLY ONLY
SEVEN DAYS AFTER THEY WERE FREED
HEADIES MOTHER PASSED AWAY. HAVE
YOU DUG A GRAVE AND BURIED HER
MOTHER WITH HER OWN HANDS. AFTER
THE WAR HEADY MET HOT TED ORDER.
TO WHOM SHE WAS MARRIED FOR
SIXTY NINE YEARS. TED WAS A
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR FROM A NEARBY
TOWN WHO ALSO LOST HIS PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS AT AUSCHWITZ.
TOGETHER THEY ESCAPED COMMUNISM
AND IMMIGRATED TO CALIFORNIA
WITH THEIR YOUNG DAUGHTERS. THEY
STARTED A SMALL BUSINESS WHICH
OVER DECADES OF HARD WORK
EVENTUALLY GREW INTO ONE OF THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND HELP THEM TO
FULFILL THE AMERICAN DREAM. THEY
LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND ENDED
EVERY FAMILY GATHERING WITH THE
WORDS GOD BLESS AMERICA. THERE
SIXTEEN THERE'S SIXTEENTH GREAT
GRANDCHILD BORN EARLIER THIS
YEAR WAS NAMED HEDY IN LOVING
MEMORY OF THE FAMILY MATRIARCH.
AND HERE WITH US TODAY ARE
HAITI'S GRANDSON IT BRIAN BURKE
AT AND GREAT GRANDSON JACK BURKE
AT A WHO I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
CHATTING WITH YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON AND THANK HAS BECOME
KIND OF THE FAMILY HISTORIAN AND
JACK IS CELEBRATING HIS
ELEVENTH. BIRTHDAY WITH US TODAY
. I THANK YOU FOR SHARING HIS
STORY WITH US SO THAT WE COULD
SHARE IT WITH ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN MISS
FRIEDMAN YOUR RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS IT'S VERY EASY YEAR
AFTER YEAR WHEN WE COMMEMORATE
THE LIVES LOST IN THE HOLOCAUST
TO START TO FEEL THAT THESE WERE
PEOPLE WHO LIVED A VERY LONG
TIME AWAY AGO IN A PLACE THAT
MUST BE VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHERE WE LIVE NOW. BUT ACTION.
THESE HAVE HAPPENED IN THE TIME
OF OUR PARENTS AND OUR
GRANDPARENTS- MOST OF US HAVE
HAD INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE WHO
BORE THE SCARS OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN GERMANY. AND GERMANY AT THE
TIME WAS CONSIDERED TO BE. NOT
JUST A CIVILIZED BUT AN
ENLIGHTENED COMMUNITY A
DEMOCRACY. AND YET THEY SLID
INTO. ONE OF THE WORST PERIODS
AND WORST ATROCITIES THAT
MANKIND HAS EVER SEEN NOT JUST
THE MURDER OF PEOPLE BUT THE
SYSTEMATIC FACTORY LIKE. PLANNED
EXECUTION OF MILLIONS OF MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN. IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE TELL SURVIVORS
STORIES NOT JUST WHILE THEY'RE
STILL WITH US AND THEY ARE STILL
WITH US AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE
FOR YEARS TO COME BUT SO THAT
PEOPLE REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
AND ALWAYS REMEMBER. THAT WE ARE
JUST AS CIVILIZED AND WE ARE
JUST AS ENLIGHTENED. AND THAT
WITHOUT BEING DELIBERATE AND
INTENTIONAL. WE ALSO COULD
ALWAYS SLIDE INTO SOME SORT OF.
ATROCITY ACTUATION WHERE WE ARE
SO WILLING TO DEMONISE OTHER
PEOPLE AND HATE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT WE ALLOW THE UNTHINKABLE TO
HAPPEN MAYBE NOT ON A GRAND
SCALE BUT EVEN ON A SMALL SCALE
AND WE CAN'T ALLOW. THAT TO
HAPPEN. WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT
A **** REALLY IS WHAT THE
HOLOCAUST REALLY WAS. I MYSELF
WAS CALLED A **** BY PEOPLE AND
BULLHORNS JUST THIS YEAR OUTSID
THE CAPITAL. WHO THOUGHT THAT
ASKING PEOPLE TO WEAR A MASK OR
GET VACCINATED WAS THE SAME AS
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE HOLOCAUST
AND WE HAVE TO STAND UP AND SAY
THAT THAT ALSO IS INEXCUSABLE.
NOW WHEN I GRADUATED COLLEGE I
WAS OFFERED A JOB FROM A FRIEND
OF A FRIEND. AND IT WAS MY FIRST
REAL JOB AFTER COLLEGE YOU KNOW
WHICH IS IN SOME WAYS YOUR MOST
IMPORTANT JOB. THAT FIRST ONE
THAT SETS YOU ON YOUR CAREER
PATH. AND I WENT TO WORK FOR A
LOVELY MAN WHO WAS A FILM
PRODUCER IN NEW YORK CITY. AND
HE WAS BRIGHTS AND HE WAS FINE
AND HE WAS A GREAT BOSS AND WE
ARE TO THIS DAY STILL CLOSE
FRIENDS IN FACT THEY WERE JUST
AT MY HOUSE A FEW WEEKS AGO HE
IS ALSO A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR MY
FRIEND BENNY CORSON WAS BORN IN
DENMARK IN NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. GERMANY INVADED DENMARK
APRIL NINETEEN FORTY UNTIL
AUGUST NINETEEN FORTY THREE LIKE
DENMARK UNFOLDED AS THE WORLD
WAR TWO WAS HAPPENING SOMEWHERE
ELSE BUT IT WASN'T ALL THAT
CHANGED IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE
OUT OF AIKMAN CENTER NEXT TO THE
GERMAN EMBASSY COPENHAGEN
ORDERING THE GESTAPO TO ROUND UP
ALL OF THE DANISH JEWS ABOUT
SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE.
WORD GOT OUT SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE MANAGE TO GO INTO HIDING
HOPING TO MAKE IT TO SAFETY IN
SWEDEN FOUR HUNDRED WERE
UNFORTUNATELY CAPTURED AND SENT
TO THE CAMPS AND THE CHAOS OF
GOING INTO HIDING BENNY'S
PARENTS DECIDED TO LEAVE HIM
WITH A GENTILE FAMILY ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF COPENHAGEN. ON A
DAK NIGHT IN NOVEMBER NINETEEN
FORTY THREE HE WAS BROUGHT TO A
SMALL BOAT THAT CROSSED THE
WATER BETWEEN DENMARK AND SWEDEN
WHICH BROUGHT BENNY AND SIX
ADULTS TO SWEDEN WHERE HIS
FATHER HAD BEEN WAITING
NERVOUSLY. FOR SEVERAL DAYS. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY MANY WORKED AS A
PRODUCTION ASSISTANT AT A SMALL
FILM PRODUCTION COMPANY IN
COPENHAGEN. AND A CREW FROM CBS
AT FROM NEW YORK ARRIVED TO MAKE
A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE
IN DENMARK. BENNY IN THE
PRODUCTION COMPANY INTERVIEWED
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
DANISH RESISTANCE MOVEMENT.%
INCLUDING THE VERY MAN ON HIS
BOAT. HE WAS TAKEN TO SWEDEN.
THAT MAN SAID TO BENNY. WE DON'T
KNOW ANY JEWS ALL I AND MY GROUP
KNEW WAS THAT THEY WERE DANES
WHO NEEDED HELP. HE AND HIS
GROUP CROSSED THE TURBULENT
SOUND BETWEEN DENMARK AND SWEDEN
A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO TIMES
UNTIL THAT MAN WAS CAPTURED BY
THE GERMANS IN MARCH OF NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR. HE WAS SENT TO A
CAMP UNTIL THE END OF WORLD WAR
TWO WERE HUMOR ACCURATELY
SURVIVED. IF ONLY ALL CITIZENS
OF ALL COUNTRIES LOOKED AT THEIR
FELLOW COUNTRYMEN FELLOW
CITIZENS AND SAID THEY ARE MY
BROTHERS THEY ARE MY SISTERS AND
I WILL PROTECT THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER OUR HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE TODAY RECOGNIZES
THAT OUR BELOVED AND RESPECTED
COMMUNITY OF SURVIVORS IS
SHRINKING EVERY YEAR. THIS
RAISES THE QUESTION WHO WILL
BEAR WITNESS TO SIX MILLION
SOULS LOST TO THE HEROES TO THE
STORIES OF THE TRAUMA. WHO IT
MUST BE US AND SO I WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M GRATEFUL FOR MY
COLLEAGUESAND TO ALL OF YOU WHO
ARE SHARING STORIES AND
LISTENING TO STORIES TODAY AND I
WANT TO BRIEFLY SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW MY OWN
FAMILY WAS AFFECTED BY THE
HOLOCAUST AND- IT'S NOT A
TYPICAL STORY BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT THERE IS A TYPICAL STORY
AND I THINK. AS YOU LISTEN. TO
THE STORIES TODAY THAT'S ONE OF
THE LESSONS TO BE LEARNED IS
THAT- EVERY STORY IS AN
INDIVIDUAL STORY EVERY FAMILY
WAS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT-
BOUND TOGETHER BY THESE.
HORRIFIC EVENTS. MY MOM AND DAD
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES DUE TO THE
FACT THAT BOTH MY MATERNAL. AND
PATERNAL GRANDPARENTS MADE- VERY
PRESCIENT DECISION AND EMIGRATED
FROM EASTERN EUROPE NOT FAR FROM
FROM KEY FIVE BY THE WAY- IN THE
LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS TO ESCAPE
AN EARLIER PERIOD OF OPPRESSION
AND ANTI SEMITISM AND WE NEED TO
REMEMBER. THAT HISTORICALLY
HOLOCAUST CAME FROM SOMEWHERE
ALL OF THAT HATE DIDN'T JUST
SHOW UP IN AN INSTANT IT HAD
BEEN. GROPPER AND GROWING
LITERALLY FOR CENTURIES. BUT MY
GRANDPARENTS MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION BECAUSE THOSE RELATIVES
WHO STAYED BEHIND WERE LITERALLY
WIPED OUT ALONG WITH MANY
VILLAGES AND TOWNS DURING THE
COURSE OF THE HOLOCAUST I
REMEMBER MY MOM COMING BACK FROM
A TRIP TO YAD VASHEM MANY OF YOU
HAVE TRAVELED TO JERUSALEM AND
HAVE HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING AT YAD VASHEM THE-
MEMORIAL TO THE HOLOCAUST- BUT
IT IS ALSO A PLACE WHERE RECORDS
ARE CAPPED AND MY MOM. AB ONE AT
THIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SEVENTIES NOW MY MOM WANTED TO
SEE IF SHE COULD FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN MANY OF HER
RELATIVES. I'VE AND
UNFORTUNATELY SHE WAS UNABLE TO
FIGHT SHE HAD NAMES- AND SHE WAS
UNABLE TO FIND RECORDS ON ANY OF
THEM. AN ENTIRE BRANCH OF OUR
FAMILY HAD BEEN LOST ALMOST
WITHOUT A TRACE. MANY OF YOU
HAVE MET MY WIFE ROBBIE BLACK IN
HER FAMILY STORY IS VERY
DIFFERENT. ROBBIE'S FATHER FRANK
BLACK WAS BORN FRANZ FAR CHILLED
IN NINETEEN TWENTY IN FRANKFORT
GERMANY. FRANK WAS THE YUNGEST
SON OF AN EXTREMELY WEALTHY
FAMILY THAT TRACED ITS ROOTS
BACK NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED YEARS
THE SPANISH INQUISITION YET
ANOTHER PERIOD OF TIME OF
OPPRESSION AGAINST JEWS. BUT HE
GREW UP FRANK GREW UP IN A
MANSION IN FRANKFORT IN ITS
FINEST NEIGHBORHOOD. AND HE
PLAYED IN THE CITY'S MOST
BEAUTIFUL PARKS AND PROBABLY
RUBBED ELBOWS WITH THE YOUNG AND
FRANK WHO WAS ALSO FROM
FRANKFORT. FRANK'S FATHER EDUARD
LARGE SHIELD WAS A WEALTHY
BUSINESSMAN A SILK MERCHANT
OPERATING FROM ONE OF
FRANKFURT'S MOST NOTABLE
BUILDINGS THAT STILL STANDS
TODAY. AND HE WAS A DIPLOMAT HE
WAS APPOINTED THE HONORARY
CONSUL TO ESTONIA. BUT AS THE
**** ROSE TO POWER THE FAMILY
SITUATION BEGAN TO DETERIORATE
DETERIORATES AND PROGRAM. IN
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX THE FAMILY
WAS FORCED TO SELL THEIR HOME
FOR A PITTANCE AND HAD TO MOVE.
EVENTUALLY A DECISION WAS MADE
THAT FRANK HIS SISTER HIS
BROTHER ONE OF HIS BROTHERS- AND
HIS MOTHER WOULD LEAVE GERMANY
AND COME TO THE U. S. THEY
SUCCESSFULLY DID SO IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT BUT THEY
WOULD NEVER SEE THE REST OF
THEIR FAMILY AGAIN. EDUARD
CLINGING AS MANY DID TO THE
FALSE HOPE THAT THINGS WOULD GET
BETTER. REFUSED TO LEAVE. AND
FRANK'S BROTHER OLDER BROTHER
MAXIMILIAN. TOOK A DIFFERENT
PATH AND JOIN THE UNDERGROUND
DETERMINED TO FIGHT THE **** IN
NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. THE EVENT KNOWN AS
KRISTALLNACHT THE NIGHT OF
BROKEN GLASS HAPPENED. JEWISH
OWNED BUSINESSES AND SYNAGOGUES
ACROSS GERMANY WERE ATTACKED
DEFACED AND TORCHED. THE
BEAUTIFUL FRANKFORT SYNAGOGUE
WAS BURNED TO THE GROUND. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE HEADQUARTERS
BUILDING FOR SHARK SHIELD OX THE
FAMILY BUSINESS WAS DESTROYED
THAT NIGHT. BY THIS TIME EDWARD
AND LOST EVERYTHING WITH NOWHERE
TO TURN AND FACING A LIKELY
ARREST BY THE **** JUST A COUPLE
OF MONTHS AFTER KRISTALLNACHT.
EDWARD INITIAL FOR AND BEST
FRIEND A MAN NAMED DOSHMAN TOOK
THEIR LIVES IN JANUARY OF
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. MEANWHILE
ROBBIE'S UNCLE FRANK'S OLDER
BROTHER MAXIMILIAN HEROICALLY
JOINED THE RESISTANCE. AND THIS
WAS IN FRANCE HE HAD TRAVELED TO
FRANCE. UNCLE MAX MUST'VE BEEN A
GREAT ACCESS ASSET TO THE
RESISTANCE BECAUSE HE SPOKE
GERMAN FRENCH AND ENGLISH
FLUENTLY. AND I SUSPECT HE MAY
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN THE FAMOUS
EVACUATION OF DUNKIRK BECAUSE IT
COINCIDED WITH THAT TIME. WHILE
HE WAS IN THE RESISTANCE. THAT
WAS A STRATEGIC HISTORIC AND
ROGUE RETREAT AND IF YOU KNOW
THE STORY OF DUNKIRK A LOT OF
THE INTELLIGENCE THAT LED TO THE
SUCCESSFUL RETREAT HAPPEN BEHIND
ENEMY LINES. ACTUAL RECORDS
BECAUSE THE **** WERE REALLY
GOOD RECORD KEEPERS. RECORDS
SHOW THAT MAXIMILIAN WAS
CAPTURED IN FRANCE IN NINETEEN
FORTY THREE. HE WAS DEPORTED BY
RAIL CAR THE DEATH CAMP AT
AUSCHWITZ WHERE HE PERISHED.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BEAR WITNESS MY FAMILY'S
HOLOCAUST. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM MISTER LIVIGNO RECOGNIZED
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER THANK YOU MEMBERS AYE
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SEVENTY IN
THAT ALL OF YOU JOIN IN THIS
REMEMBRANCE OF YAMAHA SHOW- OF
THE HOLOCAUST EACH YEAR AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR ALL OF
SOCIETY- WE REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST WE REMEMBER THE EVIL-
THE CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY
PERPETRATED AGAINST THE JEWS-
AND THAT. IS NOT BEHIND US IN
HISTORY I SHARED WITH YOU A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ABOUT HOW ON
MY GREAT GRANDMOTHER'S
NATURALIZATION PAPERS IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES IT DESCRIBES
HER RACE AS HEBREW THEY EVEN
THOUGH AS SHE BECAME AN AMERICAN
SHE WAS OTHER. LIKE SO MANY
OTHERS ARE OTHER WEATHER HERE IN
OUR OWN COMMUNITY BUT THAT
DIDN'T JUST STOP WHEN THE
HOLOCAUST ENDED. WE KNOW THAT
JEWS ARE OTHER HARPER ARE
PERSECUTED- THAT THIS ANTI
SEMITISM IS STILL ALIVE- WHEN WE
SEE VLADIMIR PUTIN USING IN. THE
HISTORY AND THE MEMORY OF THE
**** AGAINST UKRAINE OR IN MY
OWN COMMUNITY IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHERE
PAMPHLETS AND LEAFLETS ARE
DROPPED. WITH THE **** SWASTIKA
AND TALK OF KOBE BEING A JEWISH
CONSPIRACY. THAT WE ARE TREATED
AS OTHERS. JEWS ARE. AND THAT-
THAT THIS ISN'T AS MY COLLEAGUE
HAD MENTIONED EARLIER. THE
HOLOCAUST DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS ALWAYS
THERE THIS HATRED AGAINST JEWS
AND SO WHEN WE WROTE REMEMBER
THE HOLOCAUST IT IS TO PROTECT
ALL OF US FROM THIS DESTRUCTIVE
DISEASE OF ANTI SEMITISM WE HAVE
A WONDERFUL TRADITION IT'S VERY
HARD IT'S VERY CHALLENGING FOR
US TO CONTINUE INTO THE FUTURE.
OF HONORING HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
AND MANY OF THE WOMEN AND MEN
WHO I HAVE BROUGHT UP TO HONOR
HAVE PASSED AWAY IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS- INCLUDING THE MOTHER OF
MY FRIEND BRUCE RIFLE I MANY OF
YOU KNOW MY FRIEND GROUP IS
AMAZING FRIEND A TRUE ALTRUIST-
AND MENSCH- AND I HONORED BOTH
HIS FATHER BOB RAE FULL. WHO WAS
A LIBERATOR- OF THE CAMPUS AS A
MEMBER OF THE U. S. ARMY- AND
I'VE HONORED HIS MOTHER SUSIE
WHO IS A SURVIVOR OF THE
HOLOCAUST I WANT TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SUSIE. AS I DID
A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN SHE WAS MY
GUEST FOR ON THE FLOOR AND I
WISH THAT YOU COULD BE HERE
TODAY- SUSIE WAS BORN PASSED
HUNGRY SHED TO PARENTS SHE HAD
TWO SISTERS- THEY WERE TAKEN TO
CONCENTRATION CAMPS IS HE WAS IN
TEARS AND STOP. AND SHE- DURING
THE WINTER OF NINETEEN FIVE. WAS
FORCED TO WALK WITHOUT SHOES OR
FOOD IN THE DEATH MARCH FROM THE
SWATOW LABOR CAMP TO DACHAU
DEATH CAMP. AND OF THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED WOMEN. THAT BEGAN DOT
MARCH SHE WAS ONE OF ONLY ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY- SURVIVED AND
I'M SO THANKFUL THAT SHE DID. ON
JULY SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
SHE MET THAT WORLD WAR TWO
LIBERATOR BOB GRATEFUL- WHILE
SHE WAS REHABILITATING AND
RECOVERING FROM THE HOLOCAUST
THEY MET ONLY BRIEFLY. BEFORE
BOB WAS SHIPPED HOME BUT THEY
CORRESPONDED FOR TWO YEARS- THEY
WEREN'T SENDING EMAILS FOR FACE
TIME. THEY THEY THEY THEY WROTE
LETTERS AND- SHE CAME TO NEW
YORK AND THEY MARRIED AND THEY
HAD TWO CHILDREN AND DIED AND
NOW. THEY HAVE FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN NOW- IT'S AMAZING
LOVE STORY- I WISH THAT THERE
WERE MORE OF THOSE LOVE STORIES-
BUT PAID WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE EVERYBODY.
FROM THE HOLOCAUST BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME TODAY TO REMEMBER THEM AND
TO REMEMBER WHY WE MUST STAND UP
AGAINST ANTI SEMITISM. AND TO
AND TO RECOGNIZE THE STAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR LEVINE MISTER
WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT IS MY
PRIVILEGE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE C. R. ONE SEVENTY INTO-
REMEMBER OR TO AKNOWLEDGE- THE
STORY OF INSPIRING CALIFORNIA
AND SURVIVOR YEAH THEY CAME. YES
I WAS BORN IN DECEMBER NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO AND A CLOSE KNIT
RURAL JEWISH COMMUNITY OF ME OF
SOUL POLAND A TOWN THAT NOW SITS
IN MODERN DAY BELARUS. THE HOME
WAS ALWAYS FILLED WITH LOTS OF
FOOD AND LOTS OF LOVE. THEY HAD
A WORKING FARM THEIR FATHER RENT
AND DRY GOOD STORE OUT OF THE
FAMILY'S HOME. THEY WERE IN
OBSERVING HOUSEHOLD AND LIFE
CENTERED AROUND THE CADENCE OF
JEWISH HOLIDAYS AND FAMILY. GET
EXPLAINED I WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD
WHEN HE CAME OUT OF ITS UGLY
HEAD. MY FIRST INTRODUCTION WAS
WHEN A JEWISH MAN WALKING BACK
FROM TEMPLE AND I STILL REMEMBER
HIS NAME M. MINKUS WAS WALKING
BY. A LITTLE GIRL MY NEIGHBOR
SAID ZADEHIN POLISH WHICH MEANS
TO. AND WITHOUT THE BLINK OF AN
EYE ADJOURNMENTS OLDER SOLDIER
PULLED OUT A REVOLVER AND SHOT
HIM DEAD THAT WAS MY
INTRODUCTION TO THE **** NOT
LONG AFTER. THE **** ARMED LOCAL
POLISH COLLABORATORS WITH GUNS
AND TRUCKS AND GIVEN THE BOUNTY
TO MURDER AS MANY JEWS AS
POSSIBLE. THESE PEOPLE WHO HAD
LIVED PEACEFULLY WITH THEIR
JEWISH NEIGHBORS INVITED THE
JEWISH LEADERS TO A MEETING TO
DISCUSS THE **** SITUATION AND
HOW THEY CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS IT. INSTEAD OF A TOWN
HALL THE JEWS WERE FORCED AT
GUNPOINT TO DIG MASS GRAVES.
OVER SIXTY OF MANTLE'S CHIPS
LEADERS WERE MURDERED THAT NIGHT
. YEAH FATHER WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
AMONG THEM. WHEN HE RECEIVED THE
INVITATION TO THE MEETING. HE
TOLD HIS FAMILY THAT SOMETHING
SEEMED OFF. AND HE HAD TO GO
HIDE IN THE WOODS. THE FAMILY
FLED WITH NOTHING BUT THE
CLOTHES ON THEIR BACK. THEY
HEADED EAST AND JAPAN THE JEWISH
RESISTANCE. AND AS A CHILD OF
EIGHT GET A BRAVELY COMPLETED
NUMEROUS MISSIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH RESISTANCE. THEIR
FAMILY SURVIVED IN THE WOODS FOR
TWO YEARS. MAKING THEIR WAY EAST
AND NARROWLY ESCAPING THE ****
GRASS. THE ENTERED FREEZING
CONDITIONS AND PERSISTENT
HUNGER. EVENTUALLY THE FAMILY
MADE THEIR WAY TO THE RUSSIAN
FRONT AND SURVIVED THE WAR IN A
WORK CAMP IN SIBERIA. AFTER THE
WAR YEAH THIS FAMILY MOVED HERE
TO LOS ANGELES. SHE MARRIED
DAVID KEENE. A FELLOW HOLOCAUST
ABOUT. WHO SERVED AS THE CANTOR
OF TEMPLE BETH SHALOM IN LONG
BEACH FOR NEARLY FIFTY YEARS.
YET AT AN ORIGINAL WORKING MOM
OWNED AND OPERATED BOARDING CARE
HOMES. STARTING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES YET AND DAVID DEDICATED
HIMSELF TO SHARING THE STORY OF
THEIR SURVIVAL. TOGETHER THEY
WROTE A BOOK HOW YOU CAN SURVIVE
ANYTHING. AND THEY GAVE
TESTIMONY TO THE UNITED STATES
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL MUSEUM AND
THE SHOW OF FOUNDATION AND SPOKE
BEFORE HUNDREDS OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN EVERY YEAR. IT IS MADE
IT HER LIFE'S MISSION TO EDUCATE
YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST
AND THE SPOKEN TO DIVERSE
AUDIENCES ABOUT THE DANGERS AND
HEAT OF HATE AND VIOLENCE AND
THE POWER OF FORGIVENESS. AND
REMOTE MORE MIGHT WE ARE
REMINDED TODAY OF A QUOTE OF
HERS. IF YOU CARRY HATE IN YOUR
HEART YOUR LIFE GETS POISONED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER WARD MISS RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MA'AM INSTAGRAMMERS I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS AS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA JOINT LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS IN HONOR OF WHOLE
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY. TODAY WE
REMEMBER A HISTORY OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SHOWN GREAT STRENGTH AND
RESILIENCE A CULTURE THAT HAS
BEEN PRESERVED FOR THE WORLD TO
READ ABOUT AND SHE LIVED OUT ON
DATE. LIVED OUT DAILY IN THE
LIVES OF SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY.
REMEMBERING AND HONORING THE SIX
MILLION WHO PERISHED AS A
PAINFUL BUT NECESSARY GESTURE.
OF OUR APPRECIATION AND
ADMIRATION FOR THEIR-
SACRIFICES. WE REMEMBER THE
LIVES OF ALL THOSE AFFECTED BY
THE HOLOCAUST AND WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO PREVENTING SUCH AN
ATROCITY FROM EVER HAPPENING
AGAIN. STORIES ARE POWERFUL AND
BELIEVED TO BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT TRADITION THAT WE
POSSESS. HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY
IS A PAINFUL STORY FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO NEVER FORGET THE
SACRIFICES OF THOSE BEFORE THEM.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SEVENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO
MR COOPER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THAT'S BIGGER ABOUT
HALF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE SEVENTY RECOGNIZING
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS A CALIFORNIA
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY. ONE
POINT MAYBE IN CBC'S MISSION TO
DEMAND EQUITY AND INCLUSION IT'S
IMPERATIVE FOR ALL OF US IN THIS
BODY THE STATE TO FIGHT TO
ELIMINATE HATE IN ALL ITS FORMS.
AS MARTHA KING JUNIOR FAMOUSLY
STATED INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A
THREAT TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
YOU AFFECTS OTHERS WEATHERS DO
WILL EVENTUALLY AFFECT US WE
MUST ACT FOR OTHERS NOT ONLY FOR
OURSELVES. TODAY WE GATHER UNITY
TO DENOUNCE HATE AND STAND SIDE
BY SIDE IN SUPPORT OF OUR JEWISH
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AS WELL AS
ALL THE OTHER VICTIMS WHO
PERISHED. DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY RECOGNIZED
THE HEROISM OF THOSE WHO
RESISTED THE **** TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THE VICTIMS. THE
ACT OF TERRORISM DURING THE
HOLOCAUST THERE IS A POWERFUL
EXAMPLE OF OUR NATION AND
CITIZENS CAN. AND MUST RESPOND
THE ACT OF HATRED IN IN
HUMANITY. DOESN'T ISN'T INTO AND
HATE CRIMES. HAVE DRASTICALLY
INCREASED THROUGHOUT THE NATION
THE PAST FEW YEARS. WITH THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA MUST FOCUS
ON RE DIRECTING OURSELVES TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF QUALITY HUMAN
RIGHTS. INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM. WE
MUST NEVER. THOSE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THE HOLOCAUST MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE SEAL BC PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER. MISSED
CRISTINA GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I REST ON BEHALF
OF THAT LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY. WE KNOW THAT MEN AND
WOMEN AND CHILDREN ALL SUFFERED
AND WERE TARGETED DURING THE%
HOLOCAUST. I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON
HIGH JEWISH WOMAN EXPERIENCES
WHERE SHAPE BECAUSE OF THEIR
GENDER DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
PREWAR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. ANTICIPATORY
REACTIONS TO **** ACTIONS GERMAN
POLICY AND TREATMENT OF MEN AND
WOMEN AND THE RESPONSE OF JEWISH
MEN AND WOMEN TO ****
PERSECUTION AFFECTED WOMEN'S OR
DEALS. IN THE EARLY PART OF THE
WAR WITH MANY ASSUMING THAT ONLY
MEN WERE IN REAL DANGER MEN
TYPICALLY WERE PRIORITIZE FOR
HIDING AND ESCAPE. AND GET ALSO
ACROSS EUROPE WOMEN TOOK ON MORE
INDEPENDENT AND ACTIVE ROLES
BECAUSE OF INCREASED RISK TO
MEN. IN THE OFTEN BECAME THE
FAMILY'S REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
OUTSIDE WORLD. IN KANSEN I'LL
WORK ELSEWHERE WOMEN WERE
SUBJECTED TO MILLIE ATION AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND IN CAPS
BEING PREGNANT OR HAVING
CHILDREN WAS THAT THAT SENTENCE
. AT THE END OF FEBRUARY
NINETEEN FORTY TWO I'M MARRIED
YOUNG JEWISH WOMEN VOLUNTARY
REGISTERED FOR GOVERNMENT
SERVICE IN A SUPPOSED TO SHOOT
FACTORY AND THEN THAT UP A NOTCH
WITH. NINE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINETEEN H. GIRLS TO BE EXACT.
THE GOVERNMENT HAVE PAID THE
**** TO TAKE THEM TO AND TO WORK
THEM TO DEATH. THEIR JOURNEY WAS
THE FIRST OFFICIAL JEWISH
TRANSPORT OF THE NOTORIOUS ****
CONCENTRATION CAMP. UNTIL
RECENTLY THEIR STORIES HAVE BEEN
LARGELY OVERLOOKED BY HISTORY
DUE TO THEIR STATUS AS POWERLESS
ORDINARY INDIVIDUALS AND ABOVE
US ABOVE ALL ELSE AS WOMEN. THE
STORY OF THE NINE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE GIRLS IS LIVE I GUESS A
REMINDER THAT WOMEN AND GIRLS
ARE KEY TARGETS IN WAR AND
GENOCIDE AS WELL ALL THOSE
STORIES ARE NOT ALWAYS TOLD. I
APPRECIATE THE STORIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SURE TO THE OF THE
SURVIVORS AND THAT WE'RE
STANDING HERE TODAY. TO
RECOGNIZE THE ATROCITIES THAT
HAPPENED NOT THAT LONG AGO. AND
TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S STILL MUCH WORK TO DO
OUT THERE I TO FIGHT INJUSTICES
AND FOR THAT I. RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
MISTER RAMOS YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU HAVE A BETTER SPEAKER
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I WANT TO
JOIN IN THE SOLIDARITY WITH THE
JEWISH CAUCUS ON THE SOLEMN
COMMEMORATION OF THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. THIS RESOLUTION
IS ALSO A CALL TO ACTION. TO
STAND UP. AND STAND UP TOGETHER
. AGAINST ACTS OF HATRED IN IN
HUMANITY S. STATED IN THE
RESOLUTION. WE MUST ALWAYS STAND
TO REFUTE THOSE WHO WOULD DENY
THAT THESE HEINOUS CRIMES IN
HISTORY OCCURRED THOSE WHO WOULD
STILL DENY IN THE FACE OF THE
PUBLIC THESE ACTIONS ACTUALLY
OCCURRED. IN THOSE WHO WOULD
CHOOSE OF FALSE OR SANITIZE
HISTORY OVER THE TRUTH. AND
PERSONAL ACCOUNTS OF THE VOICE
OF THE VERY PEOPLE THAT THESE
ATROCITIES HAPPEN TO. THE VOICE
AND THE RESILIENCY AND THE
STRAIN OF THE PEOPLE TO SPEAK
THE TRUTH HERE TODAY ON THIS
FLOOR WHAT TRULY HAPPENED IN
HISTORY AND WHERE WE'RE HEADED
IN OUR FUTURE TO STAND UNITED.
WE STAND TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
THE TRUTH GETS TOLD TO THOSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
NATION IN THE WORLD WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY. WE MUST NEVER FORGET
WE MUST REMEMBER. AND SHARE OUR
HISTORY AND STAND UNITED. IN
LIFTING ONE ANOTHER UP IN OUR
DAILY LIVES IT'S NOW THAT WE
WILL COME TOGETHER ON THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS NOT ONLY
HERE ON THE LEGISLATIVE FLOORS
BUT THE COMMITTEES THAT WE SIT
IN SO WE COULD SPEAK UP FOR OUR
BROTHERS AND OUR SISTERS OF THE
HISTORY. THAT HAS BEEN DONE TOLD
TOO MANY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION WE
HEARD HERE TODAY FROM PERSONAL
ACCOUNTS IS THOSE VOICES THAT
NEED TO RESONATE THEN THE
STRENGTHENED WITH THE RESILIENCY
OF YOUR PEOPLE THAT WE SHARE A
COMMON THREAD. TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD OUR COMMUNITY AND
LIFT ONE ANOTHER UP AND STAND
SIDE BY SIDE IN SOLIDARITY I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER AHMOSE MISTER BRIAN YOU
RECOGNIZED. HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. SIX MILLION
KILLED ELEVEN MILLION MORE
IMPACTED. THE HOLOCAUST NOW MORE
THAN SEVENTY YEARS LATER STILL
REMAIN FRIENDLY ONE OF THE MOST
EXTREME INSTANCES OF VIOLENCE
HATE IN EXECUTION IN THE WORLD'S
HISTORY. I'M TORN TODAY BECAUSE
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE SHOULDN'T
JUST BE A DAY. LIKE AMERICAN
SLAVERY AND ALL HISTORIES OF
VIOLENT STRUGGLE AND
PERSEVERANCE THE HOLOCAUST.
SHOULD BE REMEMBERED AS A
FOUNDATIONAL COMPONENT OF ALL
HISTORIES AND ALL EDUCATION. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE VALLEY. AND MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION. EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY. THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING US THE TODAY ISN'T
JUST ABOUT REMEMBRANCE. IT'S
ABOUT ACTING BECAUSE HATE AND
VIOLENCE AND ANTI SEMITISM ARE
NOT YET GONE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS BODY TO
BE PART OF A NEW HISTORY AND TO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY OUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU MISTER RYAN MR QUIRK
YOUR RECOGNIZED. YES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SEVENTY IT
ALSO TO TELL THE STORY OF MY
FRIEND BILL SHARMAN. YEAH TO MY
RETIREMENT CAN BE OCCASION
CREEK. ON MAY THIRTEENTH.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. BILL
BOARDED THE LINER ST LOUIS WITH
NINE HUNDRED OTHER JEWS TO FLEE
GERMANY. THE SHIP KNOWN AS THE
SHIP OF THE- THEY PLANTED A BARK
IN CUBA. MOST THAN PLANNED TO
EMIGRATE TO THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT OF CUBA DID DEMAND
THAT A HALF MILLION DOLLARS AS-THE PRICE OF ALLOWING THE JEWS
ON BOARD TO ENTER CUBA. HE
REFUSED TO NEGOTIATE ON THIS
PRICE. PASSENGERS WERE THEN
DENIED ENTRY TO THE US BY
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT. EUROPEAN
NATIONS WERE WILLING TO TAKE IN
THE REFUGEES. OF THE THREE
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT. WENT TO THE UNITED
KINGDOM. I JUST WENT TO THE
NETHERLANDS AND FRANCE. WE'RE
MANY OF THEM ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
DIED AFTER THE GERMANS INVADED
THE WEST. R. HI ASK YOU REMEMBER
ALL OF THOSE WHO DIED PARTLY
WELL. IT COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED
BY US AND WE SEE THE SAME
DISREGARD FOR REFUGEES TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR QUIRK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. WE POSIT ME THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA JEWISH
COPIES. AS WELL RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR PRESENCE HERE ALLOWS US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT AND
REMEMBER WHY WE ARE HERE. AND
SPECIFICALLY WHEN THE LENS OF
THE LGBT COMMUNITY. ****
TARGETED GAY MEN SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF THE ACCUSATION. THAT
HOMOPHOBIA WOULD QUOTE. CONTINUE
TO EXACERBATE THE NOTION THAT
HOMOSEXUALS ARE UNFIT TO DEFEND
THE NATION IN COMBAT AND WOULD
DIMINISH GERMAN REPRODUCTIVE
POTENTIAL AND QUOTE. EVEN THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS WERE SEPARATED BY
THE FEAR THAT HOMOSEXUALITY
WOULD SPREAD. AND WITH RESPECT
TO THE CURRENT TIMES OF STOPPING
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER HATE. WE
STAND SOLIDLY IN RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF STANDING UP
AGAINST HATE TO ALL. AND TO THE
MEMBERSOF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
WILL ALLOW US THIS OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S REALLY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO BE REMINDED ALSO ABOUT
THIS WHOLE COSTS CEREMONY. AND
THANK YOU FOR REMINDING US TO
REFLECT AS YOU STATED HERE TO
REFLECT ON OUR COLLECTIVE
OBLIGATION TO STRENGTHEN.
HOLOCAUST MEMORY AND TO COMBAT
ANTI SEMITISM RACISM AND ALL
FORMS OF HATRED AND BIGOTRY
pCAUCUSES WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE IN THIS CHAMBER AND WE
STAND COMMITTED TO SOLIDARITY
AND STOPPING ALL HATE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MR LOW MISTER IS
THERE ANY ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES
JUST THIS WEEK FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR
BRING THIS MEASURE FORWARD THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR FRIENDS LOVED
ONES AND GUESTS FOR BEING IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER ORINDA
GALLERIES JOINING US FOR TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS- JUST EARLIER THIS
WEEK- WEEK WE COMMEMORATED THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND WE SPOKE
OF HOW THIRTY THREE YEARS BEFORE
THE ATTACKS AND THE BEGINNING OF
THE PROGRAMS AND THE- EVENTUAL
HOLOCAUST OF THE JEWISH.
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT EUROPE
HITLER REMINDED HIS GENERALS WHO
NOW REMEMBERS THE ARMENIANS JUST
THIRTY THREE YEARS BEFORE THAT.
THAT'S ALL IT TOOK THAT CONTEXT
OF TIME. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
LET'S NOT FORGET HITLER WAS
THIS- A YOUNG SOLDIER IN WORLD
WAR ONE HE SAW THE DEFEAT OF
THIS COUNTRY. AND SO HE TURNED
IT INTO THE HATE THAT WOULD
EVENTUALLY ALLOW HIM TO RISE TO
POWER. AND USE THAT HATE TO
CONTINUE STRENGTHENING HIM. SO
IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO REMEMBER
THE REFLECT THE MAKE AWARE AND
TO EDUCATE I JUST WANT TO LEAVE
WITH THE WORDS OF A CZECH WRITER
MILAN KUNDERA WHO I'VE FACED
BEFORE ON ON THESE- ON THE FLOOR
THE STRUGGLE OF MAN AGAINST
POWER IS THE STRUGGLE OF MEMORY
AGAINST FORGETTING. VERY SIMPLE
CONCEPT BUT YET SO CRITICAL IN
ALLOWING US NOT TO FORGET IN THE
GOOD TIMES WHAT WE'VE SURVIVED
AND OVERCOME IN ORDER TO NEVER
ALLOW IT AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN MR GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS- RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION I
THINK THE AUTHOR. FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR TODA WHO EVER SINCE WE
WERE STUDENTS- CAL BERKELEY HAVE
BEEN HONORED TO- STAND WITH HIM
AS AN ALLY OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE
AND OF THE JEWISH HOMELAND. IN
ISRAEL- THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO THIS AND THAT WE
REMEMBER- AND THAT THE STORIES
BE TOLD AND I'VE I'VE HAD THE
HONOR AND THE PRIVILEGE- OVER
THESE YEARS TO MEET MANY
SURVIVORS- AND HEAR THEIR
STORIES. AND AS WE TELL THESE
STORIES ON THIS FLOOR TODAY. IT
IS PART OF HOW WE OVERCOME THAT
DARKNESS. IN THAT EVIL THAT TOOK
SIX MILLION PEOPLE. FROM THIS
EARTH IS IT WE TELL THEIR
STORIES AND WE TALK ABOUT THE
SURVIVORS. THEN HOW THEY'VE
OVERCOME- AND WE TALK ABOUT
THESE AMAZING PEOPLE. AND WHAT
THEY DID AND WHAT THEY MEANT AND
WE SAY THEIR NAMES- IS PART OF
HOW WE OVERCOME THE DARKNESS.
NOW THE OTHER WAY WE DO THAT IS
BY REMEMBER IN SO THAT WE- CAN
STAND AGAINST ATROCITIES THAT WE
SEE EVEN TODAY AND WE ARE SEEN
THOSE. TYPES OF ATROCITIES EVEN
NOW TODAY IN CHINA. YOUR SEEN
THAT IN UKRAINE. RIGHT NOW- AND
THAT IS WHY IT IS EVER MORE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO STAND
RESOLUTE. US THIS. AS THIS
COUNTRY HAS- AND AS THOSE WHO
STAND WITH THE JEWISH PEOPLE SO
THERE MAY NEVER AGAIN BE A
HOLOCAUST. THANK YOU. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
WANT TO- FIRST OF ALL THANK ALL
THE COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE TODAY
FOR YOUR BUT VERY POWERFUL WORDS
ON A PARTICULARLY- THANK OUR
SISTER CAUCASUS FOR- FOR
STANDING WITH US AND ALSO FOR-
STANDING WITH US ON ISSUES THAT
MATTER AND- I THINK ONE OF MY-
HIGHLIGHTS OF MY TIME HERE IN MY
SERVICE IN THE LEGISLATURE IS
THE WAY THAT OUR CAUCUSES HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER TO ONE
PARTICULAR APPRECIATE- THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE SPOKEN UP TODAY. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR TAKING  MOMENT TO LISTEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S A REALLY BUSY
MOMENT OF OUR SESSION AND FOLKS
HAVE BEEN RUNNING AROUND A LOT
AND I KNOW HOW PRECIOUS AND
VALUABLE YOUR TIME IS AND THE-
WILLINGNESS TO REALLY LISTEN
WITH SINCERITY- IS. IS VERY
MEANINGFUL FOR ME MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND I WOULD ALSO-
YOU KNOW SHARE WITH YOU WE HAVE
SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO STORIES
YOU HEARD WITH US TODAY. WE'RE
GOING TO GET YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND
RECOGNIZE THEM IN A MOMENT- BUT
ALSO ON YOUR DESKS WE HAVE
PROVIDED FOR YOU- A LINK TO A
WEBSITE-ARE JEWISH CAUCUS
WEBSITE WHICH INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONIAL. FROM
SURVIVORS VIDEOS. PICTURES
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THAT
AND ALSO IF YOU'RE SOME KIND TO
SHARE IT. TO SHARE IT WITH
PEOPLE- IN ALL OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES. WANTED CONCLUDE
WITH. A FEW OBSERVATIONS. FIRST
AS YOU HAVE HEARD TODAY. THAT
THE HOLOCAUST FOR MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND FOR MEMBERS OF
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IT IS NOT A
HISTORICAL IT. IS NOT A
HISTORICAL A MERE HISTORICAL
INCIDENT. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS DEEPLY PERSONAL. I THINK YOU
HAVE HEARD THAT FOR MEMBERS OF
OUR CAUCUS WHETHER IT'S OUR
FAMILIES AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADED CAN'T
BE WITH US TODAY WHOSE
GRANDMOTHER WAS A HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR. BUT YOU HEARD ABOUT MR
BERMAN FAMILY HEARD ABOUT MR
BLOOM'S FAMILY. YOU HEARD ABOUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S
EXPERIENCES WITH ALL OF THIS.
FOR ALL OF US THIS IS THIS IS A
DEEPLY PERSONAL ISSUE. AND THE
HOLOCAUST WAS MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUAL TRAUMAS. BUT IT WAS
ALSO A COLLECTIVE TRAUMA.
THERE'S A COLLECTIVE TRAUMA THAT
WE AS THE JEWISH COMMUNITY FEEL.
AND IT IS SO POWERFULLY
INFLUENCE THE WAY THAT WE THINK
ABOUT THE WORLD. THE WAY THAT WE
REACT TO ISSUES THE WAY THAT WE
AS A CAUCUS NAVIGATE THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE ISSUES THAT
WE WORK ON AND IT'S SO
FUNDAMENTALLY MOTIVATES THE WORK
THAT WE DO NOT ONLY TO STAND UP
FOR OURSELVES. AND OUR COMMUNITY
UNFLINCHINGLY BUT ALSO THE WORK
AND THE MISSION THAT WE FEEL TO
STAND UP FOR OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO STAND UP AGAINST
OTHER INSTANCES OF GENOCIDE IN
THE WORLD SO STAND WITH OTHER
VULNERABLE COMMITTEES WHETHER
THEY ARE. OR ARE DEGENERATES OR
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING
PERSECUTION. AND SO WITH THAT
SPIRIT IN MIND I THINK ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUE SAID THE HOLOCAUST
IS NOT JUST SOMETHING WE SHOULD
REFLECT ABOUT IT IS ALSO A CALL
TO ACTION. WE HOPE THAT TODAY
FOR ALL OF YOU WILL BE A MOMENT
OF SOMBER REFLECTION BUT WE ALSO
HOPE IT WILL BE A MOMENT TO
THINK ABOUT OUR COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY. AS PEOPLE WITH A
UNIQUE AND SPECIAL ABILITY TO
CHANGE THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE
AND OUR WORLD TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT RACISM AND TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT BIGOTRY OF ALL
FORMS WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE ON
ACR. ONE SEVENTY. MEMBERS THE
FIRST ROLL CALL WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE SEVENTY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ALL. THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NO
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. TO MARK HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL DAY WE HAVE GUESTS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THEY
ARE SURVIVORS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS THEIR PRESENCE
SERVES AS A REMINDER THAT OUR
COLLECTIVE MEMORY OF THIS
HORRIFIC EVENTS MUST NOT FADE.
AS YOUR NAME IS RED PLEASE COME
TO THE REAR CENTER FILE TO BE
RECOGNIZED. GUESTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. OUR FIRST HONOREE IS
BRUCE RAY FOR. WHO'S READY FOR
THE CHILD OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
AND THE U. S. ARMY LIBERATOR WHO
HAS SERVED AS A LEADER AND
ACTIVISTS IN NUMEROUS JEWISH
POLITICAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUSES IN THE NORTH BAY HE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A MAJORITY
CONSULTANT AND A CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY PLEASE WELCOME
BRUCE RIFLE. SECOND HONOREE IS
BENNY CORSON. MANY. MANY CORES
IN IS A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR WHO
WAS BORN IN DENMARK WHEN HE WAS
FIVE YEARS OLD THE **** SOUGHT
TO ROUND UP AND DEPORT DENMARK'S
JEWISH POPULATION MR COURSON WAS
HIDDEN BY NON JEWISH FAMILY ON
THE OUTSKIRTS OF COPENHAGEN AND
THEN SMUGGLED OUT TO SAFETY IN
SWEDEN AFTER THE WAR MR COURSON
TOLD THE STORY OF THE DANISH
RESISTANCE MOVEMENT AND
THOUSANDS OF ORDINARY DANES WHO
HELPED SAVE OVER 90% OF
DENMARK'S JEWISH POPULATION MR
COURSON IS ALSO A PRODUCER WHO
WAS PRODUCED OVER TWENTY FEATURE
FILMS INCLUDING THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT OSCAR WINNER.
BABBITT'S FEAST PLEASE WELCOME
MANY COURSES. THIRD HONOREE IS
ANY COURSE IN. ANY CHORDS AND IS
MARRIED TO DANA'S HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR PENNY COURSON SHE IS AN
ACCOMPLISHED ACTRESS COMEDIAN
AND WRITER WHO HAS DEVOTED
CONSIDERABLE EFFORTS TO
COMPOSING ART THAT CELEBRATES
THE UNIQUE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
JEWISH WOMEN THROUGH COMEDY AND
MUSIC AMONG HER MANY CREDITS
THIS COURSE AND IS WELL KNOWN
FOR HER POPULAR APPEARANCES ON
SEINFELD. PLEASE WELCOME ANY
COURSE AND. OUR FOURTH ON A RE
IS BRIAN BURKE AT. BRIAN BECAUSE
IT IS THE GRANDSON OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS HE HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
LEADER IN NUMEROUS JEWISH
POLITICAL AND PHILANTHROPIC
CAUSES IT IS CURRENTLY WRITING
HIS SECOND BOOK ON THE HOLOCAUST
HE RECENTLY CELEBRATED THE BIRTH
OF HIS THREE MONTH OLD DAUGHTER
HEDY WAS NAMED AFTER HIS
GRANDMOTHER HATTIE ORTON WHO
SURVIVED THE AUSCHWITZ DEATH
CAMP. PLEASE WELCOME BRIAN TO
PROTECT. HONOREE IS JACK BURKE
AT. JACK MCKAY IS THE GREAT
GRANDSON OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
JACK IS A FIFTH GRADER AT SINAI
A KEEP ACADEMY IN LOS ANGELES
AND THE FOUNDER OF A SMALL
BUSINESS JACK'S AVOCADOS WHICH
DONATES 25% OF ITS PROFITS TO
CHARITY TODAY IS ALSO HIS
ELEVENTH BIRTHDAY PLEASE WELCOME
JACK PROTECT. OUR SIXTH HONOREE
IS YET A CANE. YET A CANE IS A
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR WHO WAS BORN
IN A SMALL RURAL COMMUNITY IN
POLAND AFTER REPORTING A
MASSACRE IN WHICH OUR COMMUNITY
SERVICE LEADERSHIP WAS FORCED TO
TAKE THEIR OWN GRAVES YET AND
HER FAMILY SURVIVED BY HIDING IN
THE WOODS FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS
WHERE THEY JOIN THE JEWISH
RESISTANCE FIGHTERS AND
EVENTUALLY MADE THEIR WAY TO A
WORK CAMP IN SIBERIA LESSON ONE
HUNDRED MILES FROM THE ARCTIC
CIRCLE. AFTER THE WAR YETTA
IMMIGRATED TO UNITED STATES IN
MERRY DAVID CAIN A FELLOW
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR WHO SERVED AS
A SPIRITUAL LEADER AT TEMPLE
BETH SHALOM IN LONG BEACH FOR
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS THE OTHER
DEVOTES HER TIME TO EDUCATE
YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST
AND THE DANGERS OF HATE AND
VIOLENCE IN THE POWER OF
FORGIVENESS. PLEASE WELCOME THE
OTHER CAME. SEVENTH HONOREE IS
EMILY KANE MILLER. EMILY K.
MILLER IS THE GRANDDAUGHTER OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS SHE IS AN
ACTIVE LEADER IN NUMEROUS JEWISH
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
FOUNDER OF PRESENT MEMORY WHICH
EMPOWERS THE FAMILIES OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS TO SHARE
THEIR PERSONAL STORIES IN A
COMPELLING AND EASY TO FOLLOW
NARRATIVE. AN EXPERT IN SOCIAL
IMPACT AND CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY SHE IS THE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF ETHOS GIVING
AND A SCHOLAR IN RESIDENCE AT
USC MARSHALL SCHOOL OF BUSINESS
PLEASE WELCOME EMILY KANE MILLER.
OUR EIGHTH HONOREE IS A NEED A
FRIEDMAN. DOCTOR READY TO
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN IS A CHILD OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS IN
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED SPEAKER
ACTIVISTS AN EXPERT ON HUMAN
SERVICES IMMIGRATION AND PARENTS
OF GENOCIDE SHE WAS RECENTLY
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM IS CO CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON HOLOCAUST
AND GENOCIDE EDUCATION. DR
FRIEDMAN IS A PROMINENT CIVIC
AND POLITICAL LEADER AND HAS
DEVOTED HER CAREER TO CARING FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF JEWISH
FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S SERVICES
WHERE SHE OVERSEES MORE THAN
FORTY EDUCATIONAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS FOR SENIORS
CHILDREN REFUGEES INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC BUT NOT DRAMATIC ABUSE.
PLEASE WELCOME DR ANITA FRIEDMAN. R. NINE AND FOLLOW ON OUR
NINTH AND FINAL ON A REDUCE IGOR
TOTO SKI. YOUR TOTAL SKEW HAD
MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS MURDERED
BY MOBILE **** KILLING UNITS
DURING THE HOLOCAUST AN
IMMIGRANT OF ODESSA UKRAINE HE
WAS PERSECUTED BY THE SOVIET
GOVERNMENT AND EVENTUALLY SENT
TO SIBERIA FOR HIS ACTIVISM ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
WHICH INCLUDED EFFORTS TO STUDY
AND TEACH THE HEBREW LANGUAGE.
AND JEWISH HISTORY HE IS THE HE
IS THE PRESIDENT OF AN
ENGINEERING DESIGN FIRM AND CO
FOUNDER OF A CRANE TECHNOLOGY
START UP PLEASE WELCOME IGOR
TOTAL SKI. MEMBERS AND GUESTS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A FINAL SALUTE
OF OUR SPECIAL GUESTS AND
FAMILIES THIS EVENING THIS
AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORIES AND
FOR YOUR SHARING YOUR
EXPERIENCES WITH US TODAY THIS
CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF THE HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL DAY YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE ON TO FLOOR
AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE AMENDMENTS
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO WITH
THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK ON YOUR AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TO ADDRESS THE POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS RAISED BY THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO TAKING A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENT. SEEING NO OBJECTION
AND HEARING NONE ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE
. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING ITEMS. FILE ITEM ONE THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ZERO FOUR.
THROUGH. ONE ELEVEN. R. D.
PASSED OUR.
FILE ITEM IS ONE ZERO FOUR TWO
ONE ELEVEN ARE PASSED RETAINED
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWELVE AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT UNDER
CURRENT LAW A SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAVING JURISDICTION OVER ANY
ELEMENTARY INTERMEDIATE OR
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL MAY PROVIDE
TIME AND FACILITIES TO ANY LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAVING
JURISDICTION OVER THE SCHOOLS OF
THE DISTRICT FOR BICYCLE SAFETY
INSTRUCTIONS HOWEVER THIS
SECTION'S BEEN UDATED SINCE ITS
CREATION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX. NOT ONLY DOES THIS ALSO
LEAVE OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO COULD USE THIS
EDUCATION BUT IT HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH THE INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY
AND PRODUCTS FOR STUDENTS TO BE
EDUCATED ON USING AN OPERATING
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PARTNER WITH
NOT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES BUT ALSO OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE TRAININGTO STUDENTS AND
HOW TO OPERATE BY SKILLS E.
BIKES MOTORIZED BIKES AND
MOTORIZED SCOOTERS. SINCE THEIR
INTRODUCTION TO THE MARKET E.
BIKES AND MOTORIZED SCOOTERS
HAVE PROVIDED COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEW FREEDOMS AND
MEANS OF TRANSPORTATIONS AROUND
CITIES AND TOWNS IN ADDITION TO
THE ACCEPTABILITY THESE PRODUCTS
HAVE ALSO PROVEN TO BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AND
CHEAPER ALTERNATIVES TO CARS
INSURING A NEXT GENERATION HAVE
INFORMATION OPERATIONAL
EDUCATION ON THESE PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S BEST INTERESTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY DAVIES
. SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES. I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM IS ONE OF THIRTEEN TWO
ONE FORTY THREE WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED WE WILL ON NOW TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY
THREE TO ONE SIXTY THREE. AND
FILE ITEMS ONE SIXTY FIVE.
BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY
THREE THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE AND
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE CONCERT WAS CHARGING
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY THE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PASSION
RELATIVES IN BASS THE PHILIP V.
SANCHEZ MEMORIAL BRIDGE THE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLOOR RELATIVE TO MAYOR JACK
SNYDER MEMORIAL HIGHWAY. SENATE
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER RAMOS
RELATIVE TO LANCE CORPORAL DOING
A ROLLOVER MORE HIGHWAY CROSSING
ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION FORTY TWO
BUY SOME NEW ELSE AND RELATIVE
TO DOCTOR FOR READ NADER
MEMORIAL IN WHICH- ASSEMBLY
COVERS OF ONE FORTY FOUR
RELATIVE TO THE PAUL VINCE.
REDONDO HIGHWAY ASSEMBLY COVERS
WE FROM ONE FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE LOS OF TO
LONG BEACH AND ON OUR GATEWAY
BRIDGE AS CURRENTLY ONE FOR ONE
BY WILL BE FROM AND OTHER
STRUCTURES COULD TAKE MATTHEW.
PATRICK THE NEW MEMORIAL HIGH
SENATE CURRENT SOLUTION WE FIFTY
SO BY SOME WAS OUR RELATIVE ARMY
SPA ONE MCGILL. COVER BIAS
MEMORIAL HIGH SENATE CURRENT ONE
SIXTY BY MEMBER AND CHAU TO
OFFICE NICOLAS VAN MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY ASSEMBLY COURAGE ONCE
FOUR SOME PEOPLE ROUSING
RELATIVE TO TENANT CARE SAID
JETHRO NEARING MEMORIAL. NANSEN
THE CURRENT THERE NINE BUT ALLEN
AND OTHERS OF TO A TOM GOT MORE
HIGHWAY. THE QUICK NOW OPEN THE
RIGHT. ON THE RESOLUTION. ALL
THOSE TODAY TO VOTE MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR AUTHORS ON THE ALL MY
VOTE ON THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS FOR WHICH IS A TO VOTE.
VIEWERSHIP YOUR NAME AS A CO OP
TO THE- ON CAN. PLEASE DO SO NOW
. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS. MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY TO
ONE FIFTY ONE FILE ITEMS ONE
FIFTY THREE TO ONE SIXTY FIVE
WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO. TWENTY
MEMBERS WISH TO REMOVE ANY
ADDITIONAL ITEMS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
AND I'M CALLING TO ADVANCE
HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVES. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES. I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SIX SIXTY ONE. I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY SIX SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SUM THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY SIXTY
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY EIGHT I
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS. RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY TWO I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY ONE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO IMMIGRANT
RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY SEVEN I
SIXTY EIGHT. ZERO SOME
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY TWO SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SEVEN I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO INCIDENT COMMERCE VERSION
THIRTY NINE I EIGHT NO. ZERO
THANK YOU MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
RIGHT. WOULD LIKE TO. KNOWLEDGE
IS STAFF THE GALA. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN STAFF.
MOVING ON TO CAN AND NOW.
MEMBERS WE TOO CAN HEARING TODAY
BUT THE TO ORGANISE COMMITTEE
WILL MEET YOUR AND SPACE ROOM
ELEVEN HUH. THE COMMITTEE WILL
UPON AND ROOM FOR THIRTY SO. IN
THE ABSENCE OF A JET OF
OBJECTION. THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. OR
TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WHO ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO JOIN IN MEMORY AND
HONOR OF RONALD KALANI COMARCA
RON WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA. HE
ATTENDED RENTAL CAR TAKE HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HE WAS RECOGNIZE
THIS TURNED OUT HIGH JUMPER AND
DEVELOPED HIS PASSION FOR TRACK
AND FIELD AFTER GRADUATING HIH
SCHOOL RUN ATTENDED SANTA ROSA
JUNIOR COLLEGE AND WAS NAMED A
HIGH JUMP CALIFORNIA STATE
CHAMPION. HE RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S IN KICKING ISRAELI
ARE KINESIOLOGY AT SONOMA STATE
UNIVERSITY I WOULD GO ON TO
COMPETE ON THE U. S. C. U. S. A.
NATIONAL JUNIOR TEAM FOR TRACK
AND FIELD. RECEIVING A GOLD
MEDAL IN SOUTH KOREA AND THE
PHILIPPINES IN HIGH JUMP. ON
AUGUST SIXTEENTH NINETEEN NINETY
RUN SUFFERED A CATASTROPHIC
SPINAL CORD INJURY WHILE BODY
SURFING LEAVING HIM A
QUADRIPLEGIC AND WITH WHEELCHAIR
BOUND. AFTER HIS INJURY HE MOVED
BACK TO CALIFORNIA AND LATER
RECEIVED HIS MASTER'S DEGREE IN
PHYSICAL EDUCATION FROM US IS A
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY. GOING ON TO
DEDICATE HIS LIFE TO PHYSICAL
EDUCATION. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN HE
WAS OFFICIALLY NAMED THE HEAD
COACH OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE. TRACK AND FIELD CROSS
COUNTRY PROGRAM. HE LED THEM
MOUNTIES TWO THREE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIPS FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAMPIONSHIPS AND
FIVE CONSECUTIVE SOUTH COAST
CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIPS. HAS
FOR OTHERS AND CHARISMATIC
PERSONALITY MADE HIM POPULAR AS
A PROFESSOR COACH COLLEAGUE
MENTOR AND FRIEND. RON IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LINDA HIS
THREE CHILDREN REBEKAH WENDY AND
CHARLES HIS FAMILY AND THE
THOUSANDS OF STUDENT ATHLETES HE
MENTORED OVER HIS THIRTY FIVE
YEAR CAREER WILL MISS HIM
DEARLY. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN
THE MEMORY OF RON KALANI COMARCA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. MISTER MAISCHAK
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME TODAY. TO CELEBRATE THE
LIFE OF DOUG SAWYER AND
EXEMPLARY BUSINESS LEADER WHO
CARED DEEPLY ABOUT HIS
COMMUNITY. TODAY WE HONOR HIS
REMARKABLE EFFORTS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WITH
APPRECIATION AND TREMENDOUS
RESPECT. DOUG DEDICATED THE
MAJORITY OF HIS TIME TO
IMPROVING OUR COMMUNITY OF SAN
DIEGO AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
UNITED WAY. A NONPROFIT THAT
SUPPORTS YOU SUCCESS AND FAMILY
STABILITY DOG EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVED FAMILY'S FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND WORKED AND
HOMELESSNESS. THIS IS WHERE I
HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH
DODD WELL I SERVED AS SAN
DIEGO'S FIRST COMMISSIONER ON
HOMELESSNESS. DOUG AND HIS WIFE
MARILYN BROUGHT MEANINGFUL
CHANGE TO BOTH PUBLIC EDUCATION
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES AND
HOMELESSNESS. HE WAS A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN RED CROSS
AND THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FOUNDATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
ASIDE FROM HIS OUTSTANDING
COMMUNITY WORK DOUG WAS A
SUCCESSFUL ACCOUNTANT AND
BUSINESSMAN OVER THE COURSE OF
TWENTY FIVE YEARS HE ROSE
THROUGH THE RANKS OF BANKING TO
BECOME FIRST VICE PRESIDENT OF
GREAT AMERICA BANK. THEN
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
MARKET PRESIDENT OF BANK OF
AMERICA. AMONG HIS PROFESSIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HE BECAME
CHAIRMAN OF THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
PRESIDENT AND LIFETIME BOARD
MEMBER OF THE HOLIDAY BOWL HE
WAS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE SAN DIEGO
OPERA. SAN DIEGO GRANT MAKERS
GLOBE THEATRE AND REUBEN H.
FLEET SPACE CENTER. DOUG HAD A
TRUE PASSION FOR SPORTS HE WAS A
SKILLED BASKETBALL PLAYER AND
WAS RECENTLY INDUCTED INTO THE
DISTINGUISHED KERNEY COMMENT
HALL OF FAME AT KEARNY HIGH
SCHOOL. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
COLLEGE WITH AN ACCOUNTING
DEGREE HE BECAME A PRO BASEBALL
UMPIRE IN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE.
HE WAS RARELY FOUND AT PETCO
PARK READY FOR THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES OR QUALCOMM STADIUM
CHEERING FOR HIS COLLEGE TEAM
THE AZTECS. DOUG WAS A CLOSE
FRIEND IN A WONDERFUL COMMUNITY
LEADER. IS AFFERENTS HAVE AIDED
US AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY'S
MEETING IN HONOR OF DOUG SAWYER
. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. FOR
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
APRIL TWENTY NINTH NO FLOOR
SESSION. NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY MAY SECOND FLOOR SESSION
WILL BEGIN AT ONE PM. THE
GERMANS ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED AND
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
DR COURT SO MOVES. F. MISTER
KILEY SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MAY SECOND AB ONE.